i accidentally became a meme and this is
that story
i'm tazonday i am probably best known
for the viral video
chocolate ring and have also done a lot
of other stuff
i was in graduate school on a career
path to become
a historian i made music as a hobby
while i lived in minneapolis i got tired
of dragging equipment to open mics in
the middle of the winter in minneapolis
where it's very cold
youtube came along and i said hey why
don't i
start filming music in my living room
and putting it on this youtube thing
and it ended up being bigger than i
expected
the riff had been a riff of mine for
many years
the lyrics i wrote over a period of
about six weeks
as a serious ballad about racism in some
ways perhaps it's a literal metaphor for
me having brown skin and also the way
that i play the riff on the piano being
a little bit rain
like i uploaded chocolate rain to
youtube as an afterthought
it wasn't intended as the final version
it was just an experimental
ballad and poem it did not blow up
immediately someone
eventually posted it on digg.com someone
saw it there they posted it on 4chan
i would say it became viral largely in
part
because i had a voice body mismatch you
know i
look like bruno mars i sound like barry
white i move like mr bean
and a lot of 4chan's audience saw me as
a potential patron
saint as sort of like oh this is a nerd
he's
totally not self-aware and he's being
big and loud
and this is like perfect and it
started to go massively viral i did the
worst satellite interview ever on cnn i
had no
experience in public relations it's an
awkward nerd plucked out of his living
room
and everybody three of the four major
labels of the time
i want to sign me as an artist everyone
is contacting me to sing at their kids
bar mitzvah at their corporate party
i just kind of said yes and i didn't
know what yes
meant necessarily the dr pepper video
was a fun video
some people criticize it in some ways
everybody did that you know michael
jackson used his songs and major
sponsorships
loud all richie and whatnot so i did
have a little bit of a precedent for
doing that type of pivot with the song
people who work at ad agencies they'll
tell me
that video was in a case study that i
read in college and i'm like
oh i didn't know that was in a marketing
case study i have been
very lucky to pursue a career in
entertainment
both acting voice work narration and
other things that stemmed from that
viral moment of chocolate rain
why wasn't the world ready in 2007 for
a serious message about racism that
perhaps it was
ready for in 2020. in 2007
youtube was not considered mainstream
new things would become viral
in a novelty economy around 2012
recommendation engines started to show
people what they wanted to see on the
internet
it sort of supercharged the ability of
people to fall off onto their own
islands
of their own prejudices and biases
and live in a reality distortion field
so there was a sort of lag time where
anti-racism and progressive thought
had to mobilize itself against
that onslaught what gives me hope is
that a 12-year-old who is watching
chocolate rain today
has many more tools to understand the
actual message of a critique of
institutional racism
than a 12 year old who was watching it
in 2007.
[Music]
[Music]
you